so literally i've you know i set up a
profile
um not so long ago probably a week or
two ago
and already on that profile is 173
friends requests
and that's of a child you know that's it
that's the profile of a 12 year old girl
and i can guarantee that that some of
them will be linked to rings
pedophile rings
[Music]
i experienced some some things as a as a
child that i really shouldn't have gone
through
um that i never got justice for i never
got answers for
so it kind of took me to
a dark place i saw one day
a live video of a pedophile being stung
and it just it intrigued me
and it just it started from there i've
stung
a lot of different sexual predators from
all different walks of life and
now i'm used to the same
it's the same path are the same they
come out with the same excuses i was
hacked or
you know i didn't know what i was doing
or i was drunk or
you know all these different things and
that's when you realize
that it's you know the the realization
is set in the actual
this thing that they've been hiding for
so long is now out
the cat's out of the bag talking about
how you've got that
blank profile so literally i've you know
i set up a profile
um not so long ago probably a week or
two ago
and already on that profile is 173
friends requests
and that's of a child you know that's it
that's the profile of a 12 year old girl
and pretty much all of them
are from england and i can guarantee
that that some of them will be linked to
rings
pedophile rings what's the one
you feel proudest stuff we had a team of
d cars working for us
and um
the a guy was under a profile called
danny williams on facebook
he was talking about bullying the kids
talking about you know
um anal sex with the kids and it just
got really really bad
to the point where i was even telling my
decoys not to engage in conversation
because it was just vile he was a bullet
um a narcissistic bullet bizarre redder
released under investigation so he was
under investigation at that point and
then we turned up and
stung him but i put a picture of him on
the page probably
half an hour 40 minutes after we'd left
and left the police station
and within 10 minutes i was contacted
off a 17 year old girl
who had been raped by him from the age
of 12
upwards she'd never told anybody in her
life that she'd been raped or abused by
him
and i was the first person that she
disclosed to um
i instantly knew that i needed to put
her in touch with the police if she was
willing to do that
she did that and the following day she
went and gave a statement and secured
five counts of rape on him
and on the fourth of june just connie
was jailed for eight years
that's a real person that's a real
12 year old who's had to live through
those times
and then just you know just because i
put a picture on a facebook page
for her to come forward and disclose one
that she's been raped and abused by him
but then to go
own it and follow it through he had no
no option but to plead guilty
what a strong inspirational young woman
why are you wearing a mask um
because it's not about me what i don't
want is people stopping me in the street
and saying oh my god you know you're a
pedophile
because i've seen all the other hunters
go down that road and i've seen
you know that the whole facebook persona
take over that's not me it's not who i
am
i'm just doing it because i can and
because i want to and it's the right
thing to do
pedophile hunters get a lot of a lot of
[ __ ] in
in the you know in the media
we're portrayed as vigilantes but we're
not
in any way you shape our farm bringing
about our own laws this is the law of
the country
that we're abiding by and this is you
know every single case that we've
processed and put through has been
charged and found guilty
there's not too much vigilante about
that to me
are there people you wouldn't it's it's
a very gray area
in in what we do because there's
there are people online that are
vulnerable themselves for instance if we
get someone
who starts speaking to one of the decoys
and we suspect that that person might
have some kind of learning difficulties
contact at that point is stopped and
then we'll reach out to
adult social services and you know
sometimes the police to try and
as much as it sounds they've got that
person from themselves
it takes five minutes to check a child's
device literally five minutes
um there's not many you know there's
probably five or six apps that children
go on um that are the most popular
platforms and they're
also most popular for grooming so if
you've got a child that's on say
snapchat or instagram or whatsapp or
and you don't know who your child is
talking to then really you should know
who your child is talking to because
they could be speaking to anybody
the risks online are very very real and
your children are in danger
if they're left unsupervised on an
iphone or
a tablet while i do what i do and i've
you know i've done it successfully for
nearly three years
predators are still able more than able
you know it does happen a predator was
able to get through to my son
and message him on instagram and and say
you know this was this was only
probably about two months ago and and
say oh you know i want you to send me
pictures i'll pay your money
we are seeing that as a direct result of
the facebook
page being there and the awareness
that's generated you know we're seeing
real results i've pretty much now
dedicated my life to it
before i started that like i really
struggled with my identity
and and who i was and what i was meant
to be and where i fitted into society
if i can stop one person just one person
with this
from becoming another version of me and
and having to
live the same kind of life that i have
then you know that that's the power of
one
you'll never truly understand how many
people you're reaching but as long as
it's one then you know job's done
it's quite possibly the best therapy
that i've ever had
because it's exposure therapy every
single time i go out on the road apart
from today
i'm stood in front of a pedophile um
asking them why they're doing what
they're doing and i've never got the
answer i've never i'll never be able to
understand what they do but
um every time we we get
a result it's it's as if little mike
gets a little bit of peace
you know a little bit of uh you know a
little bit more of the jigsaw
slots into place
you